c'est supposé être la circulaire ça
devrait être tous des bons prix mais ce
n'est pas le cas il ya aussi les attrape
nigaud parce que depuis plus de dix ans
cinzia cunéo traque les prix en épicerie
avec sos cuisine elle constate que ce
n'est pas parce qu'un produit dans le
circulaire les toubabs le supermarché
affiche sans ça veut pas dire que c'est
un vraiment bon prix un général on est
habitué sur la première page dernière
page c'est bon mais même dans ce cas là
j'ai vu souvent que c'est un peu
difficile à comprendre comprend pas
exactement qu'est ce qui est spécial
en effet le contenu des pages
intérieures des circulaires de
supermarché n'est bien souvent que de la
promotion
l'idée étant de nous attirer dans le
magasin on voit quand même une
agressivité dans le marché les personnes
qu'ils ont les deux pieds sur le pot
fait attendre quels clients viennent
chez lui il faut s'attendre pour le
client donc nécessairement faire des
promotions par des rabais pour la
trichine en supermarché les rabais sont
offerts par trois entités différentes
soit par les anciens y j'ai à métro et
provigo par exemple directement des
fabricants ou encore des détaillants
eux-mêmes pour le consommateur ce qui
prime c'est le rabais c'est ce qu'il
souhaite prouver si une entente qui fait
entre souvent en scène il manufacturier
pour définir différents avaient attiré
l'attention du client sur un item plutôt
qu'un homme qui les manufacturiers sont
très intéressés à ce que bien entendu
vous achetez l'offre du pub celui du
concurrent et ces jeux là ce fonds se
négocient cuillère pour ça que vous avez
certes un système qui sont plus investis
que ce soit un petit pont qu'on peut
déchirer ou encore un autocollant qui
est apposée sur le produit
si on a un exemple de promotion
manufacturier va se combiner avec une
formation qui est déjà présente en
magasin non pour le consommateur les
possibilités d'aller les
quelque chose intéresse il ya des rabais
qui sont effectués directement par le
gérant ou bien parce qu'on veut sortir
certains produits qui approche de la
date de péremption ou encore parce qu on
a fait une entente directement avec un
fournisseur elle les produits frais ces
visites m qui sont souvent plus
intéressants au niveau des marges sont
plus sensibles à gérer parce que
justement ces dépôts du pays savent donc
c'est un espèce de danse entre le
détaillant est le fournisseur pour cette
semaine c'est mon produit que je veux
que ça donc cette danse la samba à des
promotions des rabais des îlots
particulier on va faire du marchandisage
en face de marchandisage croisé on va
par une formation on va vendre un item
en raid et à l'achat d'un autre item
dans toutes ces choses là font partie de
l'écosystème des prix dans un magazine
c'est pas parce qu'un produit est arabe
et que celui d'à côté est pas moins cher
non plus fait c'est vrai qui sait c'est
là que ça devient important de bien
comprendre les promotions de se référer
aux besoins et aux prix aux sans grade
qui est disponible sur la tablette
subtil de retrouver d'aller leur garde
et puis le consommateur doit savoir
compter ça on peut pas passer à côté
en effet à moins de bien connaître les
prix il faut toujours se référer à
l'indication du prix par unité de mesure
pour comparer les produits
est-ce qu'en général on peut se souvenir
peut-être d'une dizaine de produits mais
c'est difficile de se souvenir
absolument de tout pis les formats aussi
son différent donc il se peut qu'on
pense que c'est un bon prix pour nous
aider sos cuisine offre un outil gratuit
d'évaluation des prix on tient compte
des saisons on tient compte de la rareté
on tient compte des différentes
grandeurs formant donc on a un prix au
kilo
donc on peut comparer sur base homogène
et sur la base de sa pour l'utilisateur
il va dans le magasin et y voit son mon
fils est fait il est qui le prix puis on
lui dit facilement si c'est très
avantageux ça veut dire que ça arrive
rarement
si c'est avantageux si c'est comme ci
comme ça aussi c'est vraiment pas un bon
prix le consommateur est toujours très
friands de rabais sont elles vont être
attirés par une tablette où il va y
avoir une indication comme quoi y'a un
rabais qui est en action donc les plus
de chances qu'ils prennent les produits
où il ya une étiquette de rabais que
celle où il ya un problème
or on voit une étiquette ce match est
sans provision j'ai l'impression
justement il arrive qu'un produit soit
mise en promotion sans toutefois subir
une baisse de prix c'est possible mais
je vous dirais qu'en général
le client pas dupe non plus qui a des
référents donc il connaît par exemple
pris cette habitude payer pour un item
en particulier donc il va s'y référer
généralement vaut mieux être vigilant
car une affichette qui attire
l'attention n'est pas un gage de rabais
cemac les deux pour 16 dollars 6 juin
alors justin obligé d'acheter 2 6 3 tout
est clair dans le cas des promotions à
l'achat de plus d'un article
vous n'êtes souvent pas obligé d'en
acheter plusieurs pour profiter du
rabais
à moins que cela soit indiqué sur la
fiche à 1 dollar 50 sont lâches et à
l'unité
quoi qu'il en soit il ya toujours moyen
de faire de bonnes affaires
en magasinant on dit aux gens de ne pas
être fidèle on peut aller à deux
magasins on peut sauver faut jouer la
game d'un circulaire la conclusion selon
moi reconnaissez vos prix pour planifier
sa moi qu'est ce qu'on achète ne pas se
faire ce train distraire par les sirènes